Sì.
Olá, pessoal. Nossa, que prazer que é
para mim táar aqui com vocês, né? Fico
muito contente de estarmos aqui falando
para um público tão grande e falando
coisas tão importantes que vai rolar
essa noite aqui com nessa live. Então,
para quem tem problema de memória, que
acha que tá cruzando aquela linha onde
começa a ter um uma diminuição da sua da
sua memória, da sua cognição, do seu
aprendizado, que não consegue tomar mais
decisões como tomava antes, não consegue
ter aquele pensamento ou ter um
brainfog, que é como se tivesse uma um
uma venda nos olhos, não consegue pensar
direito. Fico muito contente de você est
acompanhando a gente, porque hoje a
gente vai falar sobre a importância de
rejuvenecer nosso cérebro com dicas
super importante, tanto pra memória como
também para Alzheimer. Então, a gente
inicia essa live falando da sua do desse
grande momento, né, que esses dois
grandes médicos me inspiraram a fazer o
programa do Recode, onde os dois têm
essa certificação também.
A gente vai conversar sobre isso. E
recode é reverse cognitive decline in
Alzheimer. Isso significa que já existem
trabalhos e estudos mostrando que é
possível sim você melhorar, você
diminuir a intensidade e até cuidar-se
desse desse desse grande mal que nós o
principal, eu acho que o ponto aqui é a
gente entender que existem formas da
gente prevenir isso. E para isso eu
tenho o grande prazer de ter aqui a Dra.
Juliana Castro.
e o Dr. Alan Dutra, que fazem parte
desse grupo, né? E a gente vai conversar
sobre isso hoje também. Talvez tenhamos,
eu não sei, eh,
ainda o Dr. Tipo Whtney ficou de estar
conosco aqui. Estamos no aguardo dele.
Se por acaso não der para ele participar
dessa vez, por qualquer motivo pessoal
que possa ter, contamos com ele numa
próxima eh numa próxima apresentação.
Queria então pedir primeiramente pra
Dout. Polana Lies always first, né, Dut?
Então, com certeza não conhece
integrativo e a gente vai est falando
sobre a importância do record para
restabelecer tanto a a saúde cerebral,
assim como rejuvenecê-la, para que a
gente possa ter maior clareza, falar de
memória e também falar de como tratar o
Alzheimer. Então, para isso, queria
muito apresentar para vocês a Dra. da
Poliana Castro, que já nos conhecemos há
há alguns anos, né, e temos tido
uma interação bem bacana para que isso
possa acontecer no Recode, a parte de
medicina, odontologia, nutrição. E eu
tenho aprendido muito com esse com essas
duas feras da saúde integrativa. Então,
Poliana, se você pudesse, por gentileza,
se apresentar e comentar conosco como
que você conheceu o programa Recode e
depois passar pro Alan e depois a gente
vai pro segundo assunto, né? O que que é
o Recode?
Eh, então, eh, eu sou médica
neurologista.
Ah, inicialmente eh, fiz a minha
formação tradicional eh, através da
Residência Médica e Neurologia. Eh,
depois eu fiz mestrado em neurologia e
neurociências na UNIFESP, na Escola
Policina,
eh, e ah, fiz subespecialização
eh em doença de Parkinson e distúrbios
do movimento. Eh, e como eu sempre tive
eh uma predileção por estudar doenças
neurodegenerativas,
a minha tese de mestrado foi em
acometimento cognitivo ah na doença de
Parkinson, né? Então, eh, eu fui um um
elo entre o distúrbio do movimento e a
demência na no momento em que eu estava
estudando pro meu mestrado.
Eh, eh,
posteriormente a isso, eh, eu comecei a
a me aprofundar dentro da medicina
funcional, né? Eh, fiz pós-graduação,
eh,
em medicina funcional. eh e depois
prática ortomolecular e uma série de
outras eh de outras formações dentro da
da prática integrativa.
Eh, e fiz também a a formação, a
certificação internacional do método
Recode.
Eh, então isso é um um pouco a respeito
da eh da minha formação, né? Eh, e aí,
eh, como eu conheci, eh, foi eh,
justamente na época em que eu comecei a
estudar medicina funcional,
eh, dentro da pós-graduação mesmo, é que
eu comecei a a, eh, a ouvir mais sobre o
que que havia eh dentro da eh das
práticas integrativas aplicadas à
neurologia, né? Então, foi nessa época
que eu ouvi falar eh sobre o protocolo
de code, né? E daí comecei a estudar eh
sobre o método naquela
época.
Muito bom, muito obrigada, viu? E Alan,
e você como que você conheceu? Bom,
primeiro você puder se apresentar e
também comentar pra gente como você
pens,
né? que a gente tá transmitindo
principalmente nas minhas eh mídias. Mas
o meu nome é Dr. Alan Dutra, eu sou
formado há mais ou menos 28 anos. A
minha formação original é cirurgia geral
e urologia.
Aproximadamente uns 10 anos eu mudei
totalmente a minha prática para
trabalhar com medicina funcional
integrativa estilo de vida, por conta de
vários desafios pessoais que eu tive.
Primeiro com a minha saúde e com a saúde
da minha esposa. A minha esposa tinha
uma doença autoimune. Ela tinha eritma
nododoso, que era muito difícil tratar
pelas técnicas convencionais.
E também eu tinha uma enxaqueca de
repetição, eu tinha intestino irritável
e minha qualidade de vida tava muito
ruim,
porque eu trabalhava em vários
hospitais, vários serviços
e
de modo que esses desafios que eu tive
na minha vida pessoal, eles foram
determinantes para que eu buscasse
alternativas. Aí eu comecei a estudar
medicina automcular e depois que nasceu
meu filho, ele foi diagnosticado com
TEIA, eu ainda aumentei mais ainda esses
estudos.
e fiz várias formações na medicina
funcional integrativa, fiz a a pós do
Albita Einstein, fiz a pós-graduação do
Lai Ribeiro, depois eu fui fazer a
formação lá nos Estados Unidos do
A4M, né, que é um instituto de medicina
funcional bem conhecido lá nos Estados
Unidos. E quando eu tava fazendo a pós
do Lai Ribeiro, eu acabei conhecendo o
livro do Recode. Então, eu tinha acabado
de lançar o livro do Recode em inglês. E
eu conheci esse livro quase que por
acaso. Eu comecei a estudar em inglês
esse livro e eu fiquei fascinado porque
era um resumo de tudo que eu tava
estudando de medicina funcional. É como
se fosse um resumão. Eu fiquei tão
empolgado que comecei a fazer vídeos a
respeito. Então acho que eu devo ter
sido a primeira pessoa no Brasil que fez
vídeo sobre o protocolo Code. E o mais
interessante, eu tinha vários pacientes
que frequentava os Estados Unidos e um
deles quando voltou de lá falou: "Olha,
tá tendo o curso do Total Breaden". Ou
seja, foi um paciente meu que me
informou, sabia que eu tinha interesse
por esse assunto, que eu tinha lido o
livro, que eu aplicava já os
conhecimentos do livro do o fim do
Alzheimer, né, o nome do livro traduzido
pro português.
E eu acabei procurando lá a equipe do
Dr. Bradsen e
me inscrevi então no programa do Recode,
fiz o curso, eu acho que eu fui o
segundo da América Latina a fazer, o
primeiro do Brasil e eu fiz o Recode
1.0, que era em parceria com o IFM, com
Institute for Functional Medicine, e
depois eu fiz o Recode 2.0.
Foi essa a minha história com Bicode. E
assim, para as pessoas entenderem,
algumas pessoas ficam muito curiosas de
saber porque que um urologista tá
mexendo com doença neurodegenativa.
Primeiro que eu tenho um interesse
pessoal sobre esse tema. Eu tenho
familiares com a doença, tenho eh quatro
pessoas na família com a doença. E
também a questão que eu descobri que a
abordagem do recode era totalmente em
cima de uma medicina funcional, uma
medicina de corpo todo, não era algo
relacionado a uma especialidade, apesar
de ser uma uma doença neurológica, o
protocolo recode é um protocolo de
medicina funcional. Então, de maneira
alguma a gente tenta ou o ou tem a
intenção de substituir um especialista,
mas é porque realmente os especialistas
hoje em dia tem uma visão muito
fragmentada da medicina, tem uma visão
muito compartimentalizada. Então a gente
tem que voltar, dar um passo atrás e
estudar a medicina como um todo, a
interligação entre órgãos e sistemas.
Isso, o recode, eh, foi assim que ele
começou, porque o Dr. Dale Braden, ele é
casado com uma médica de medicina
funcional lá nos Estados Unidos. Quando
ele estudava o modelo do Alzheimer no
rato e na mosca, ele tava fazendo como
todo mundo tava fazendo na época. e tava
buscando uma molécula única que tinha
que ser modificada através de algum tipo
de medicamento para que houvesse, né, a
reversão da doença ou o tratamento
adequado à doença. Então ele descobriu a
duras penas, né, e também pela
influência da esposa dele que a doença
era multifatorial. E aí que ele
desenvolveu o protocolo para atacar 36
mecanismos moleculares diferentes para
eh ele foi o primeiro a ter um resultado
consistente na reversão do dé cognitivo
e no tratamento da doença. E saiu o
estudo Evanteia, talvez o Chip Whtney,
se ele puder se juntar a nós, ele pode
comentar sobre isso também, mas
recentemente saiu o estudo Evantea, que
foi o primeiro randomiz control trial,
primeiro estudo randomizado duplo cego,
mostrando que esse protocolo é sete
vezes melhor que o Leenbi, que o
Lecanumab, que é uma droga aí super
badalada, que acabou de ser lançada no
Brasil, foi largamente
eh divulgado na imprensa sobre essa
droga. E então o protocolo realmente ele
é bem trabalhoso, ele é bem completo,
complexo até, mas ele vale muito a pena
porque ele é a única ferramenta que nós
temos hoje em dia que de fato altera a
evolução da doença.
Então essa é minha história com coach
tá tendo eco aí.
O Dr. Chip Whitney tá tentando entrar,
ele tá aqui comigo no telefone.
Ah, e está tentando entrar. Eu peço, dou
alguma orientação para ele?
É usar o link, tipo assim, é o mesmo
link, não tem dificuldade.
Muito bem, então vamos tocando aqui, né?
Enquanto
o Rodrigo tá tentando acertar lá com o
tipy, eu queria perguntar para você,
Dra. Poliana, eh, como é que tem sido a
sua experiência com protocolo recode?
E também uma coisa que eu tenho
curiosidade, eu sei que você trabalha
com equipamento,
eh, que
também o Dr. Fábio Bexell também
trabalha. Eu queria que você falasse
como é que têm sido os seus resultados e
associando o protocolo com o
equipamento.
Eh,
oi, pessoal. Eh, desculpa só eh o Dr.
Tipo WN pediu para se desculpar que ele
não tá conseguindo conectar e que ele
vai ter em breve paciente para atender
agora, mas a gente ficou depois de
marcar uma outra com ele, tá bom?
OK.
Então vamos tocar em português mesmo,
tá bom?
Tá bem.
Pode falar, por favor.
Eh, então, a minha experiência com
Protocolo Recode, eh, sendo uma
neurologista que vende uma formação
tradicional, né? Eh, eh,
é comum, é um presente você poder, eh,
ah, passar a, a, utilizar um método que
seja eh eh que agregue tanto em
comparação eh ao que eh ao que eu via eh
dentro da prática tradicional, né?
Então,
eh,
para mim não tem nem não tem nem
comparação o que que o que eu eh o que
observava de evolução, como que era a
evolução do paciente, observar a
evolução do paciente eh do do declínio
progressivo que o paciente tem eh pela
própria evolução natural da doença, eh,
e mesmo quando é introduzido o
tratamento farmacológico.
Eh, e a partir do momento em que eu
comecei a utilizar
eh a medicina funcional e e
principalmente os conceitos do protocolo
recode, que embora seja um programa
extenso, trabalhoso, que exige muito do
paciente, da família, eh existe muita
exige muita eh modificação de estilo de
vida, exige muita eh modificação da
dinâmica familiar, porque não é o
tratamento de eh de um único braço. A
gente precisa de vários braços, né, de
todo mundo arregaçar as mangas para eh
para promover tudo que precisa, pro
paciente conseguir fazer eh o tratamento
dele da melhor forma possível e dentro
daquilo que ele conseguir eh aplicar de
tudo que é orientado dentro do
tratamento,
né? Então, eh, para mim, é, é assim,
mudou a minha prática clínica, a, a
abordagem da medicina funcional mudou a
minha prática clínica para melhor, tanto
no tratamento das doenças
neurodegenerativas,
quanto no tratamento eh dos das doenças
neurológicas da infância, como autismo e
TDH, porque também tenho eu tenho dois
filhos com autismo. eh foram eles que me
levaram a eh a procurar novas
abordagens, né? Eh, e eles que me
ensinaram que havia assim mais o que a
gente pudesse estudar e mais o que a
gente pudesse fazer eh dentro de eh para
poder agregar dentro da dos tratamentos
em neurologia, né? Eh,
então, ah, para mim foi muito
transformador, eh, poder, eh, eh,
conhecer a as práticas práticas
integrativas que eu ainda continuo
estudando, eh, o que mais, né, a gente
pode fazer eh para tornar o mais
positiva possível eh eh a evolução do
paciente, eh, para máximo auxiliar em
relação a como que a gente pode auxiliar
na no melhor prognóstico em relação à
autonomia, em relação à melhora da
qualidade de vida do paciente, já que a
neurologia tradicional ela é conhecida,
como dizia um um grande professor da
da neurologia da UNIFESP, né? A
neurologia é conhecida como uma ciência
de brilhantes diagnósticos e pobres
resultados dentro do meio tradicional. E
aí, como neurologista, a gente acaba eh
muitas das vezes, né, se frustrando por
eh em muitas situações a gente eh dentro
dos tratamentos que a gente conhece da
do do meio tradicional,
daquilo que esteja recon reconhecido
dentro das melhores práticas e dentro da
medicina baseada em evidências e daquilo
que é recomendado dentro dos guidelines
internacionais, eh a gente acabar muit
das vezes eh eh vendo que eh acaba
assistindo né, o declínio do paciente eh
de forma assim inexorável,
eh, principalmente dentro das condições
neurodegenerativas,
né? Eh, então a o protocolo recode e a
abordagem integrativa da neurologia como
um todo eh me auxiliaram a eh a ver as
coisas de uma outra forma, de uma forma
mais positiva e conseguir enxergar muito
mais resultados nos tratamentos
eh com impacto muito mais positivo eh na
qualidade de vida e na autonomia eh dos
pacientes do que quando usava apenas os
tratamentos tradicionais, né? Eh, e em
relação à terapia de neuromodulação que
eu utilizo, que atua na epigenética e
que utiliza um professor,
é o React, né? Você fala do React, eu
queria saber sua experiência com React,
que é é o nome da da tecnologia, né?
É.
Eh, então, eh, o que que acontece? E por
mais que haja eh haja estudos eh sobre
eh a a terapia com essa tecnologia para
pessoas com doença de Alzheimer, eh a é
um é um pouco é é muito menos trabalhoso
do que o protocoling. O protocol code é
bastante amplo, né? Muito mais
minucioso, muito mais estudado, né? Mas
o que eu observo eh na minha prática
clínica, eh é que eles parecem ter um
efeito sinérgico, né? Eh tendo em vista
que os pacientes que, eh, conseguem
fazer ambos os tratamentos eh acabam
somando efeito, acabam tendo efeitos eh
soma de efeitos positivos, né, na na
evolução clínica deles, né? Eh, é isso
que eu que eu observo na minha prática
clínica.
Muito bom. Eu eu queria também só
comentar aqui com o pessoal que eu
acabei não tendo oportunidade como que
eu conheci o Record. Primeiro conheci o
Record através do Alan e da Poliana, né,
que já tinham me falado. E quando eu fui
convidado para dar uma aula lá na
International Academy of Medicine
Toxicology,
quando o pessoal soube que eu ia dar
essa aula, o o tipo Wney entrou em
contato comigo e falou: "Olha, será que
você poderia tá falando um pouquinho
sobre o Ecode, né, na aula eu fiz um
trabalho para mostrar um trabalho
integrativo para mostrar como que os
procedimentos odontológicos auxiliavam
no rejucimento cerebral e auxiliavam na
microculação, na micronutrição, na
oxigenação e principalmente na limpeza
cerebral, possibilitando tirar aquela
célula de uma possível homotoxicose.
Aí eh,
pediu para falar um pouquinho. Eu
naquela época eu já tava fazendo, já
tinha me inscrito, né? que vocês já
tinham falado tão bem nesse programa,
que tinham tido resultados tão bons. Eu
falei: "Bom, então vou aproveitar e aí
tive a oportunidade de também mostrar um
uns eh uns slides que eles gentilmente
me cederam. E o que mais me chamou
atenção, que é o primeiro programa
multidisciplinar
com uma visão integrativa. Então é
importante a gente entender que precisa
ter o médico, precisa ter o dentista,
precisa ter um nutricionista, precisa
ter o fisioterapeuta ou personal,
precisa ter, se necessário, dependendo
do nível, o health coach, né, para tá
auxiliando a pessoa a se organizar.
precisa ter,
dependendo do caso, a enfermeira para tá
ali, né, possibilitando todo o
tratamento, a parte emocional, a parte
de gerenciar o estress. Então, muitas
vezes a gente precisa da parte emocional
para est cuidando disso, né? E aí você
tem um monte de coisas, inclusive fazer
exercício na esteira com oxigênio.
Alguém tem experiência dessa parte do
desse protocolo que você utiliza o andar
com a máscara de oxigênio? Alguém tem
experiência?
Eu tive alguns pacientes que fizeram
dessa maneira. Rodrigo, alguém tá com eh
tem que baixar um pouco o volume do
altofalante porque tá dando do eco. Tem
muita gente reclamando aqui no no
YouTube. Não sei quem se é o Rodrigo ou
se é Poliano, mas enfim.
Eh, sobre essa sua pergunta, eu tive
alguns pacientes que fizeram, tá? A
gente quando fez a pós do Lai Ribeiro, a
gente ficou sabendo que existia esse
protocolo de utilizar o oxigênio com
exercício e também com alguns
ultracêuticos associados. E eu fiquei
surpreso de ver que também no protocolo,
né, durante a formação, eles mencionaram
sobre isso, né, que
o protocolo aqui no Brasil tem é
conhecido por outro nome. Me fugiu o
nome agora, talvez a Polana se lembre,
mas daqui a pouco eu acho que volta na
minha mente. Mas enfim, tive alguns
pacientes, uns dois ou três que fizeram
e o resultado foi bem interessante,
Rodrigo, tá? tanto o uso de oxigênio
hiperbárico, é uma pena que câmera
hiperbárica é uma coisa que ainda não é
tão acessível. Eu até pensei em instalar
uma câmera na clínica. O problema é que
se você quiser que o convênio pague, tem
poucas aplicações clínicas que eles
pagam. Então, e aí ia ficar um
investimento um pouco alto de montar a
câmara e sem saber direito como é que ia
ser, quantos pacientes iam iam aderir,
mas tanto a o oxigoterapia hiperbárica
quanto o a o exercício com oxigênio,
eles são comprovadamente muito eficazes
para ajudar a resolver um dos problemas,
né, um dos tipos da doença de Alzheimer,
que é o tipo circulatório. Então eles
realmente ajudam bastante e obviamente
sozinhos não vão ter uma ação super
eficaz porque o programa, uma coisa que
eu aprendi com o programa é que os
pacientes têm pelo menos três tipos,
três subtipos de Alzheimer associados e
a maioria tem três, alguns têm quatro.
Então, mesmo que você melhora a
microcirculação e oxigenação, ainda vai
ser necessário cuidar da parte do
metabolismo glicolítico, né, da do
chamado diabétes tipo 3. Vai ser
necessário diminuir a inflamação, em
muitos casos vai ser necessário entrar
com fatores tróficos no cérebro. Então é
muito interessante. E outra coisa que
tenho visto também que funciona, que é
bem legal, é a fotobiomodulação,
né, que tem sido bem aí divulgado
recentemente, muitos trabalhos novos
falando da eficácia, tanto para
depressão, para doenças
neurodegenerativas, para várias doenças
neurológicas.
É outra terapia também de suporte muito
interessante. A eletroneuroestimulação e
a estimulação magnética também são
interessantes. Eu fiz a pergunta pra
Opuliana porque o REAC é uma tecnologia
interessante, mas que até o momento eu
não vi os americanos comentarem sobre o
Reac, né? E como a Poliana
já tem uma experiência já há alguns anos
e aplicando o REAC e eu não trabalho
ainda com essa tecnologia e poderia ser
até uma coisa bem interessante para
adicionar ao protocolo, né? E ela falou
muito bem, o protocolo é muito complexo,
infelizmente, no sentido de quê? de que
você tem que mexer muitas peças ao mesmo
tempo. Mudança profunda na dieta que os
pacientes têm muita dificuldade de
seguir, mas é fundamental sem essa
mudança dietética não se tenhos
resultados.
Recentemente fiz uma live com uma
nutricionista que é uma das maiores aí
especialistas em dieta
eh cetogênica e ela mora em Portugal e a
gente percebe que até entre os
nutricionistas tem muita resistência com
a dieta citogênica e pouca formação e
informação. Então, até para você
conseguir um nutre que tenha bastante
intimidade com a dieta cetogênica no
Brasil é um pouco difícil, porque a
formação e acadêmica normal, eles não
falam quase nada disso e tem que ser uma
coisa na pós-graduação e pouca gente tem
essa formação nessa área. Então, a dieta
é um grande desafio para muitas pessoas
também. O jejum é um grande desafio que
também é uma peça muito importante,
especialmente potadores de apo cópia ou
duas cópias do APE4. Você tem que fazer,
se tiver uma cópia, tem que fazer 14
horas ou duas cópias, 16 horas de jejum.
A questão também do exercício físico,
muitos idosos chegam até mim já um
comprometimento físico que não consegue
mais fazer atividade física da maneira
adequada.
Isso é também um desafio para vários
pacientes. Tem muitos que chegam já com
déficit cognitivo acentuado, moderado,
já não conseguem fazer também o estímulo
cerebral da melhor forma possível, fazer
exercícios mentais cerebrais.
H, as pessoas de modo geral t uma
dificuldade muito grande fazer meditação
ou técnicas de relaxamento. Acho que o
brasileiro deve ser o povo mais
estressado do mundo. Eu já vi um estudo
falando sobre isso, que o brasileiro era
um dos povos mais estressados do mundo
pela instabilidade eh do nosso país, né?
Toda hora aparece uma novidade, não é
boa geralmente, né? Então as pessoas
ficam sempre na ponta dos pés esperando
o próximo golpe. Então isso é uma coisa
que atrapalha muito as pessoas
aprenderem técnicas de meditação, de
relaxamento.
E ah o distúrbios de sono também é uma
coisa impressionante. Eu acho que 70% do
nosso paciente tem um disturbo de sono e
uns 40% deve ter a pneia obstrutiva do
sono. Então é muita coisa para mexer ao
mesmo tempo. E as pessoas quando chegam
no consultório médico, muitas vezes elas
não estão habituadas com essa visão
holística. Elas estão acostumadas aí ao
médico pegar uma receitinha, ir para
casa e tocar a vida como sempre foi. E a
gente tem que fazer esse papel de
praticamente virar um professor. E eu
tenho muito material nas minhas mídias
para ensinar isso. E a gente dá um monte
de coisa escrita, livros que eu mandei
traduzir pro português, paguei eh
tradutora para traduzir o livro e vídeos
e mais vídeos. Mas mesmo assim, eh, às
vezes é complicado você fazer uma
educação sistematizada na família toda,
porque quando vem um desses idosos,
geralmente ele tem três ou quatro
filhos, que eles são de outras gerações
e boa parte deles tem três ou quatro
filhos. Aí tem um filho que concorda,
tem um filho que discorda, o outro não
tá nem sabendo e fica aquela confusão.
Tem vários idosos, inclusive que até vi
a experiência da Poliana sobre isso, tem
vários idosos que às vezes ficam fazendo
temporadas, fica morando um tempo na
casa de de um filho, outro outra
temporada na casa de outro filho. E aí
um filho concorda, outro discorda. E é
outra coisa, coordenar esse trabalho de
família é um grande desafio também.
Seu microfone está fechado, Rodrigo.
Então, eu não sei. Eu acho que melhorou
a a o áudio,
ô Alan. Porque eu acho que talvez possa
ser o microfone da Poliana.
Não é? Tá tendo algum vazamento de áudio
de algum altofalante aí. Eh, não sei de
qual de qual que é.
O o seu áudio dá para escutar? Tá tudo
bem. Eh, eh, mas das próximas vezes
talvez a gente conseguir um microfone
melhor, mas tá dando para te entender.
Tá bom. Então, queria saber a sua
opinião, as dificuldades que você tem
encontrado
no
essas que o Alan começou a a comentar e
depois eu queria falar sobre a APN e o
Vancou, né, que a gente tem tratado de
uma forma mais simples,
mas conta pra gente, por favor.
Bom, em relação às dificuldades
encontradas, eh, dentro do que eu
observo na na minha prática clínica, eh
concordo com Alan quando ele comenta
sobre eh a questão de de divergências eh
entre membros da família, porque afinal
de contas o paciente idoso eh que venha
para tratamento, para um tratamento
novo, eh para um tratamento que
infelizmente ainda é pouco difundido, eh
um tratamento ainda aa que ainda não se
ouve falar em congressos médicos
tradicionais,
né? né? É um tratamento que basicamente
o paciente quando descobre sobre a
existência eh do tratamento a partir a
partir da de uma busca da família, eh
geralmente um membro da família é aquela
pessoa que tá buscando o que mais a
gente pode fazer, existem novos
tratamentos e essa pessoa que geralmente
eh busca conversar com os demais filhos,
com demais membros da família, eh para
verificar se todos concordam de tentar
um novo tratamento, né? Eh, e o paciente
que muit das vezes eh, ah, muit das
vezes não tem nem a percepção adequada
do próprio adoecimento, porque existe
uma condição dentro do do adoecimento na
doença de Alzheimer muito frequente, que
é a nosognosia, que é a alteração da
capacidade da percepção do próprio
déficit neurológico. Então, muitas vezes
o paciente não não tem o alerta devido
em relação ao que tá acontecendo com
ele. família leva o paciente paraa
consulta e o paciente muitas vezes fala
assim: "Nossa, eu tô aqui porque a
família tá me trazendo, mas eu tô
ótima". Eles dizem que a memória tá
ruim, mas a minha memória para mim tá
ótima. Eu tô aqui só porque eles me
trouxeram, né? Eh, e aí, eh, muitas
vezes pode ter alguém da família que tá
ali super dedicado de quero fazer o novo
tratamento, eh, e super engajado. E muit
das vezes outros membros da família eh
falam assim: "Ah, mas esse tratamento é
novo". Mas quando eu conversei com outro
médico neurologista, ele não me falou
sobre, então, será que é mesmo eh útil a
gente tentar esse novo tratamento? E aí
quando você faz as orientações eh eh
iniciais a respeito de tratamento, né,
quando o paciente precisa começar a
modificar hábitos de vida, isso mexe com
a dinâmica da família, né? Eh, nessa
hora que
eh a eh a eh eh começa frequentemente
começa a surgir algum tipo de de
dificuldade ali eh no dia a dia e aí é
necessária a colaboração da família para
que haja, por exemplo, mudança de
hábitos alimentares, né? Eh,
e aí sem eh a colaboração da família
fica difícil de o pacienteir conseguir
atingir os alvos que ele precisa eh
dentro de cada parte do tratamento, né?
Então, ah, mas aí se a gente precisa
outras questões em relação à mudança de
hábitos de vida, se a gente precisa eh
atividade de implementar atividade
física, eh aí precisa de alguém para
levar o paciente para isso, quanto que
você pode contar com demais familiares
para que isso se faça, né? Eh, ah, se a
gente precisa fazer estimulação
cognitiva e se o paciente tá numa
condição em que ele ainda não consegue,
em que ele não, por exemplo, não dê
conta de fazer sozinha e precisa de
algum suporte para fazer isso, né? O
quanto que a família consegue ajudá-lo
eh em relação a isso, né? né? Então
precisa ter alguém disponível para isso.
Então é relativamente é relativamente
frequente
de eh haver um membro da família
ou dois ou dois membros da família
eh que sejam aquelas pessoas que estão
mais engajadas e que se unem para tentar
auxiliar o paciente a implementar a as
orientações do tratamento.
Eh, e
a
muitas das vezes outros outros membros
acabam muitas vezes não se envolvendo
muito, né? Então isso de fato eh
frequentemente funciona, acontece como
um obstáculo, né, ao tratamento. Eh, e
também assim,
eh, eu sempre falo que assim, quando
você tem eh um filho que você precisa
levar para tratar, quem é que vai
determinar o que vai ser feito
tratamento para aquele filho?
são os pais. E aí são só duas pessoas
para concordar ou discordar. Quando você
levando o seu pai e a sua mãe para ser
tratado, em geral, vai depender de
quantos filhos eh tão envolvidos ali na
tomada de decisão para saber se vai dar
certo ou se não vai aquilo que você
precisa, né? Então, frequentemente o
tratamento acaba eh ficando mais a cargo
de um ou dois membros da família, que
sejam aquelas pessoas que tão ali, topam
arregaçar as mangas para proverci,
eh, e muitas vezes outros membros da
família acabam não se envolvendo muito,
né? Então, tem a questão de quem
contribui, quem colabora no dia a dia
para que as coisas sejam implementadas,
para que as orientações sejam
implementadas. Eh, dois, quem concorda
ou quem discorda, né? Porque às vezes eh
o tratamento não consegue nem ser
iniciado se eh a maior parte da família
não concordar, né? E aí eh um dos
filhos, por exemplo, eu falo assim: "Ó,
doutora, me sinto como um mandorinha que
não faz verão. Então, se eu não consigo
ter ajuda dos meus eh dos meus irmãos
para prover isso pro meu pai ou paraa
minha mãe, aí na minha realidade atual,
nesse momento, eu não consigo
implementar um tratamento. Isso pode
acontecer. E o terceiro ponto é fator
financeiro, porque eh a o tratamento
custa, todo tratamento custa, né? Eh e o
recode custa porque ele muda um monte de
coisa na vida do paciente. Você gasta
com médico, você gasta com
suplementação, você gasta com dieta,
você gasta com modificação de aptito,
você gasta com dentista, você gasta com
um monte de coisa, né? E aí, eh, nessa
hora que a gente vai, eh, conseguir ver
o que o que que a família consegue se
mobilizar para fazer, porque às vezes,
eh, ah, uma filha traz a mãe para tratar
e fala assim: "Ó, doutora, eh, eu queria
muito fazer o tratamento, mas acontece
que sozinha eu não consigo eh não estou
conseguindo bancar todos os custos do
adoecimento, porque eu tenho que cuidar
das despesas financeiras da dos meus
filhos, eh, da minha casa e da minha
mãe, eu preciso dividir com os meus
irmãos." E aí, eh, não, não tô
conseguindo essa, essa parceria, essa
divisão, então não tô conseguindo
implementar tudo que precisa, né? Então,
essas são adversidades frequentemente
encontradas, né? Eh,
é, você falou algumas coisas aí que me
identifiquei bastante, né,
a respeito
dessas situações de família mesmo que
você acaba de escrever. Uma coisa que eu
aprendi fazendo o protocolo recode, que
me chama muito atenção, é que o esforço
para uma pessoa mudar o estilo de vida,
quando parte dela, quando ela tem
incognição suficiente ainda para
promover mudança, é um esforço
infinitamente menor do que quando você
depende de um terceiro. É uma coisa
desproporcional. Então, por exemplo, se
eu, Alan, resolvo mudar meu estilo de
vida, mudar alimentação, atividade
física,
começar a empreender hábitos que eu não
fazia antes, para mim é difícil, mas é
ainda muito mais fácil que quando
depende de um filho ou filha
eh aplicar isso em mim. Então isso é uma
das coisas que mais me chamou atenção
aplicando o protocolo recodo,
esse fenômeno que você falou que o
próprio paciente não percebe a queda
dele, eu vejo bastante na prática
clínica também. É uma coisa bem
frequente isso daí. E isso é uma coisa
que atrapalha muito o tratamento também,
porque a família tem que empreender um
esforço muito grande para poder
convencer o próprio doente a tomar as
medidas que tem que tomar, né? Então, é,
isso gera um desgaste emocional às vezes
muito grande, dependendo do caso.
Eu eu queria só só colocar que dentro de
todas essas dificuldades, eu agradeço
demais vocês. Eu acho que é o meu
microfone, né, que tá com
Olha, alguém falou que eu era culpado,
Rodrigo, eu até conectei o um fone com
fio no próprio microfone,
mas não mudou não. Eh, tá, tá, tá, tá.
continuar com eco.
Não, mas o melhor sempre
olhe, feche o seu, por gentileza, só pra
gente ver.
Vamos ver então. Mas eu eu queria
primeiramente agradecer essa experiência
de que vocês têm colocado, né? Eh, e
queria comentar que dentro desse
protocolo foi o que inspirou a gente
montar o Record, o a a o SIS, né, o
simpósio internacional de saúde
integrativa, que vai acontecer agora dia
13, 14 e 15 de março, que vamos ter a
participação especial do Dr. Whitney,
professor também do programa do desse
desse
programa Recode,
eh desenvolvido pelo Dr. Dale Britz e
que temos Dra. Lan, Dra. Poliana, né,
que fazem parte, assim como eu também, e
que a gente vai ter toda essa forma,
então desde a vai ter professores
nutricionistas para falar sobre a
importância, por exemplo, do intestino,
a importância do
da limpeza do fígado, a mitilação,
processo de desintoxicação de metais
tóxicos, a desparasitação,
a dieta cetogênica, o jejum,
intermitente, a parte emocional, a parte
odontológica. Vamos ter a Dra. Regina
Mcash falando sobre a importância da
respiração, apneia, ronco, né? convidei,
não tive ainda o OK, mas o
tem um dentista, o Dr. John, que teve
aqui o a a a o CIS passado, que ele fala
também sobre a Pineia Ronco, falou muito
bem, convidei ele. Vamos ter o Jerry
curatola falando sobre o microbioma
bucal e também eh trazendo a saúde
cerebral, que é o lá de Nova York, que
para mim é um dos maiores dentistas
biológicos do mundo. O J tem tem uma
série de estudos organizados e vai falar
sobre o microbioma.
A gente vai ter também ah
nutricionistas, né, falando de toda essa
importância.
Vamos ter falando sobre cavitação óssea,
porque a gente vê estudos do Lechner
informando que o CCL5, que é aquele
soldado que acaba crescendo dentro
daquele osso que não cicatrizou de forma
correta, ele vai iniciar o processo e
tem milhares de artigos relacionando,
são mais de 4.000 artigos relacionando o
CCL5 por causa dessa captação óssea,
juntamente com o problema de Alzheimer.
Vamos também est falando sobre a
importância do mercúrio, que também tá
relacionado ao Alzheimer e doenças
autoimunes, neurodegenerativas,
degenerativas.
Vamos ter a
também falando sobre a parte de medicina
regenerativa. Então, tanto a Dra. Ana
Moreira de Portugal, como também que vai
est contribuindo, que foi a presidente
do congresso lá em Portugal, vai est
participando da sua experiência e eu
tive a oportunidade de conversar com ela
no congresso mundial que teve no Rio de
Janeiro e eu fiquei impressionado com a
experiência que ela tem, com esses
resultados que ela tem tido. Então, mais
uma internacional aí pra gente. O Felipe
Caquete vai também falar sobre medicina
regenerativa. Então a gente vê que
depois que faz todo o processo, não deu
resultado, ainda tem ainda a opção de se
fazer as células tronco. E isso a gente
também vai tá mostrando. Sem contar que
vai ter uma feira enorme eh aberta ao
público, exatamente para verem as
tecnologias,
as opções que tem de tratamento, os
produtos que tem. Então, 13, 14, 15 de
março agora 2026, se você tiver mais
interesse, depois busca aqui. Acredito
que a gente possa deixar o link, né,
Dra. Alan, para que o pessoal possa
entrar e conhecer mais. Dra. Alan vai
estar lá conosco, Dra. Paulina vai estar
conosco, Dra. Jea Quental,
Dra. Elizete Cfer. Bom, enfim, são 40
grandes profissionais da área de saúde.
Vamos ter também um assunto novo, porque
a gente entende que é muito importante
controlar comida, né? Mas também é muito
importante a gente controlar a água, a
qualidade da água. Então, para isso,
pedi para um grande amigo meu,
Claudinei,
que ele pudesse est explicando pra gente
sobre a importância da água e como que a
tecnologia que ele desenvolveu pode
estar ajudando isso. A gente vai ter o
professor Irineu também.
Bom, são 40 amigos que vão estar conosco
e é um evento que vocês precisam
participar. Peço ajuda na divulgação
dessa live para quem é para aquelas
pessoas que você acha que possa estar
sendo beneficiado. E queria também pedir
eh para vocês agora pudessem estar
falando durante 3 minutos cada um, dando
um spoiler do que cada um vai falar no
durante esse evento. Pode ser
sim.
Tr minutinhos para cá. Eu vou falar dos
subtipos do Alzheimer, dar uma
introdução ao tema e explicar a partir
do trabalho do Dr. Dale Brads a da
equipe dele, como é que ele chegou
nesses seis subtipos. Então, minha
palestra vai ser a respeito disso.
E você, Poliana?
Bom, no simpósio internacional de saúde
integrativa, eh, eu vou falar sobre eh
sobre eh estudos eh científicos eh
publicados sobre o protocolo code, né?
Então, a minha palestra vai versar sobre
os estudos, mas principalmente sobre o
último estudo que é o estudo Evanteia,
comentado há pouco no início da live,
eh, que eh foi um estudo cujo pré-print
eh foi disponibilizado eh agora no final
de final de dezembro, 30 de dezembro de
2025, foi disponibado o preprint, ainda
vai passar pela revisão eh
eh por pareview,
né? para que seja publicado ainda esse
ano, possivelmente a partir de fevereiro
ou março, eh, o estudo já deve tá eh em
definitivo publicado, né? Eh, e que esse
estudo ele traz resultados assim
arrebatadores,
né? Eh, em relação eh à efetividade do
protocolo reod. Eh, ah, em relação a que
só dando um spoiler, falando um
pouquinho sobre o que que tem de
resultado positivo, né? 100% dos
pacientes eh que se submeteram ao
tratamento com o protocolo Recode
tiveram eh reversão de teclínio
cognitivo. Eh, grande parte deles
tiveram eh eh um desempenho cognitivo ao
final do estudo superior ao que era o
habitual deles antes eh do adoecimento.
Eh, então quando comparado ao grupo B,
eh, que fazia o tratamento tradicional,
eh, os pacientes que submeteram o
protocolo Code tiveram eh uma espécie de
evolução eh em que eles melhoravam em
relação, por exemplo, à memória. E os
pacientes que não estavam fazendo
protocolo recode, eh, e que estavam eh
basicamente tendo um tratamento
tradicional, eles acabavam apresentando
o declínio eh eh da memória. mas tem uma
série de outras eh de outras habilidades
cognitivas eh que foram eh examinadas e
onde se observaram resultados
estarrecedores. E além disso, eh, o
próprio comparativo feito, foi feita uma
análise comparativa
eh, com a, eh, as drogas mais
recentemente lançadas para o tratamento
da doença de Alzheimer dentro da
intervenção tradicional, que são
anticorpos monoclonais, que é a terapia
antiamiloide. eh
já tem duas dessas drogas já aprovadas
pela Anvisa no Brasil, eh que é um
tratamento
eh bastante caro, infelizmente, né, mas
que trazia uma promessa de poxa, agora
parece que temos algo eh que possa
trazer um pouco mais de esperança ali
pros pacientes quando de Alzheimer. E aí
pelo menos em torno de ah, será que tem
alguma estabilização em torno de 30% na
evolução da doença? E aí quando você
compara a análise comparativa feita
entre o recode eh e os resultados eh
publicados dessas intervenções com esses
anticorpos para a terapia antiamiloide,
que é o tratamento mais moderno, eh, que
se tem dentro da prática tradicional
para doença de Alzheimer, eh o que se
observou é que eh o recode se mostrou
sete vezes o effect size, que é o
tamanho do efeito eh do protocolo
recode, eh nos pacientes com doença de
Alzheimer, ele se mostrou de sete a
quatro vezes maior.
do que o tamanho do efeito eh do
Lecanemab, do Donanemab, que são as
drogas da terapia antiamiloide aprovadas
no Brasil, né? Eh, e não só no Brasil,
mas aprovada já há tempos nos Estados
Unidos, em outros locais do mundo
também. Eh, então, eh, esse é um momento
muito importante, eh, para o protocolo
Recode, porque a gente sabe que
para se fazer pesquisa e para se
publicar os resultados que se tem na
prática clínica, eh, demanda tempo,
demanda pessoas, demanda patrocínio.
Então, muit das vezes, aquilo que você
observa na prática clínica com
tratamento que está começando, lançando
mão da declaração de Rin, que permite ao
médico oferecer ao paciente tratamentos
novos, eh, que possam agregar pro
paciente, né, até que isso esteja
devidamente publicado na literatura,
muit das vezes leva eh anos a fio ou
mais de uma década, né? Eh, então a
gente tá num momento em que eh muitos
estudos já foram publicados de 2014 para
cá, né, vários estudos foram publicados.
Eh, e agora esse estudo ele traz um peso
eh e ele eh eh importante eh no sentido
de que eh ele ele demonstra com mais
propriedade ainda do que os estudos
anteriores eh a efetividade do protocolo
recode, né? Então, eh esse vai ser eh o
tema da minha palestra, porque eh o
assun assunto de maior importância que
eu entendi que precisava eh trazer para
eh para apresentar. as pessoas precisam
saber eh que o protocolo Code existe e
precisam saber o que que tá sendo
publicado, porque afinal de contas eh ah
não é algo assim que ah, tem alguém ali
que inventou que não, é ciência, tá
publicado. Sim.
Em Portugal, Rodrigo, quando a gente foi
a Portugal fazer o congresso lá do Porto
e eu fiz a minha apresentação, eu já
apresentei um, já não era o resultado
final do Evanteia, mas era o os
primeiros resultados que
foram divulgados, porque teve uma live
na semana passada, se eu não me engano,
que o Dr. Dale Bradsen ele divulgou a
publicação, o pré-print que a Dra. Pulen
tá tá se referindo agora.
e ele também divulgou o link do estudo
que a gente pôde fazer um download. Mas
antes mesmo disso, eu já tinha eh
levantado as informações eh no
clinicaltrials.gov
e eu apresentei no final, não sei se
você lembra, eh no final eu apresentei
alguns achados já iniciais desse vanti.
Ah, foi brilhante sua aula. Parabéns.
Gostei bastante.
Obrigado. Esse vante aí é um estudo
realmente revolucionário, que é o
primeiro randomiz control try, ou seja,
o primeiro estudo randomizado
controlado, né? o aleatorizado,
controlado, que fala sobre isso, porque
as grandes críticas que tinham, também
mostrei isso na minha aula lá em
Portugal, as grandes críticas que todos
faziam a respeito do protocolo recode é
que não tinha esse tal de random mais
control trial, não tinha um RCT, né? Ah,
não tem ciência, não tem ciência. Muito
bem. O problema é que o paradigma hoje
da ciência,
ainda se baseia muito no cartesianismo,
né? Renê Decart foi um gênio, mas eh
hoje em dia a gente não pode mais basear
a biologia de sistemas em eh na parte
cartesiana, porque eh o que funciona
hoje para doenças complexas e
multifatoriais são múltiplos estudos de
n de um. O que significa isso? Você tem
que comparar a pessoa antes e depois de
uma intervenção. Não adianta mais a
gente fazer esses estudos que a gente
pega 2000, 3.000, 5.000 pessoas e dá o
mesmo remédio para pessoas completamente
diferentes, que tem uma biologia
totalmente diferente, que tem eh
particularidades completamente
diferentes, porque assim, dentro daquele
grupo de 5.000 pessoas, vai ter 10%, vai
ter o subtipo 1, vai ter 10% subtipo 2,
20% do subt e aí aquela intervenção que
vai atuar num dos subtipos, ele vai
pegar só um pedaço pequeno daqueles
5.000 pessoas e isso vai dar no final
uma estatística fraca e aí você vai
ficar pensando que aquele remédio não
funciona, quando na verdade ele é
extremamente eficaz para um subtipo.
Então a gente tem que evoluir nesses
estudos aí, usar biologia de sistemas,
sistemas complexos, porque de fato essa
maneira tradicional, entre aspas, que se
faz ciência, ela tá obsoleta para
doenças crônicas e multifatoriais e
complexos, como é o caso da doença de
Alzheimer. Então, isso foi uma coisa que
ao estudar o tema me chamou muita
atenção e que de fato a gente vai ter
que usar metabolômica, todos os estudos
ômicos para poder evoluir com isso, para
que a gente possa eh fazer esses
múltiplos estudos de N de um, começar a
comparar a pessoa no começo, no final do
tratamento e não ficar juntando um grupo
super heterogêneo, um estudo grande,
para no final falar que aquele aquela
intervenção única não é efetiva. Então
eu acho que isso é uma grande evolução
que a gente precisa passar agora no nos
estudos clínicos desse tipo de doença.
Muito bom. Eu eu queria eu queria também
falar que no CIS agora a gente vai ter o
Afons Salgado.
Você comentou sobre a importância da
foto de modulação e o Afonso Salgado é
um professor que já mora em Orlando, é
brasileiro, mas ele estudou em Harvard
exatamente alguns protocolos de
fotobiomodulação
e a gente vai ter os aparelhos dele
participando da nossa feira. Então, se
você quiser conhecer mais sobre essa
nova tecnologia de fotobomodulação e
como ela atua na melhora da memória do
rejuvencimento cerebral e também de
doenças eh neurodegenerativas,
vamos lá, 13, 14 e 15 de março desse
ano, tá? E eu queria falar só
rapidamente o que que eu vou tá falando
nessa parte, porque a odontologia ela
também para para que a gente possa tá
colaborando para a memória e o
resultado, é muito importante o papel da
odontologia para remover os focos
inflamatórios e infecciosos que acabam
que acabam prejudicando.
Melhorou?
É, tá um rundo.
Oi. Bom, então queria, acho que melhorou
agora, né?
Melhorou.
A parte odontológica, ela é muito
importante porque da mesma forma que a
gente tem eh fatores inflamatórios no
intestino que preparam o nosso nosso
corpo para luta e para fuga, preparando
o nosso corpo para uma guerra,
o nosso sistema ele começa a preparar
uma série de defesas. E essas defesas a
longo prazo é que vão prejudicar a nossa
saúde cerebral. Então, quando a gente
tira os focos inflamatórios infecciosos,
tira as toxinas,
a gente também acaba melhorando todo o
processo de micronutrição,
microcirculação, oxigenação e limpeza.
Então, uma coisa rápida, só pra gente
entender, são os problemas periodontais,
que são bactérias que vão se acumulando
ao redor do dente.
A gente tem também a carne, a gente tem
os canais que muitas vezes não são bem
tratados, não por causa do dentista, mas
porque a diversidade anatômica acaba
dificultando a limpeza completa.
lesões dentro do osso que acabam levando
à necessidade de crescer uma um soldado
nosso que é o CCL5 que acaba
prejudicando também. Fora isso, a gente
tem que o que o amaladeital, que ele
produz o mercúrio, o mercúrio ele tem
uma afinidade muito grande eh pela nossa
a nossa célula cerebral, assim como o
tiroide, rins, fígado. Então ele vai nos
prejudicar muito. a gente precisa
remover o amalgama dental, a gente
precisa tirar as correntes galvânicas,
precisa pensar que na comunicação do
cérebro com o resto do corpo existe
também uma uma comunicação elétrica e a
gente tem que entender como ela acontece
e tirar essa essa
eh essa interferência de forma que seja
super favorável para o paciente.
Então, tudo isso vai ser falado durante
esse evento e queria convidar mais uma
vez vocês a participarem e também a
queria convidar a conhecerem melhor o
trabalho do Dra. Ana Dutre e Dra.
Poliana Castro que estão aí nas mídias,
né? Depois queria que vocês colocassem,
eh, falassem aqui pro pessoal para quem
ainda não conhece, para tá seguindo. O
meu é Dr. Rodrigo 25 e eu tô sempre
trazendo uma série de dicas e novidades,
altas tecnologias para que possa também
tá tratando dessa parte. Como a gente tá
chegando no final aqui, eu queria que
vocês deixassem uma mensagem aí para
quem tá nos assistindo e para que a
gente possa encerrar. Antes de mais
nada, queria agradecer aos dois. É uma
pena que o Dr. Tipo não poôde participar
dessa vez, mas ele vai participar
conosco e trazer mais informações ainda
sobre o o apesar que vocês falaram, né,
com tanto conhecimento, eu eu babo
assim. E fico super orgulhoso e vocês
dois de estarem trazendo o recode pro
Brasil e serem essa grande referência
aqui sul-americana.
Uma vez me indicaram pacientes
sul-americanos porque acho que não tem
ainda dentistas, né? Não sei se tem ou
não, mas eu acredito que também vocês
devam estar recebendo pacientes, né,
sul-americanos do do mundo todo, pela
competência que vocês mostram, pelos
resultados, pelo cuidado, pela
humanidade. Então, só tenho a
parabenizar vocês dois e agradecer.
Agora, como
estamos encerrando, queria ouvir por as
suas sua mensagem. Depois o Dora
Rodrigo, gostaria muito de agradecer a
você pelo convite de fazer essa live pra
gente falar sobre o BRode. Eh, muito
importante a gente conseguir divulgar eh
sobre o método.
eh a parabenizar você pelo seu trabalho,
porque eh eu vejo muito eh o quanto você
eh o quanto eu recebo de elogios eh dos
tratamentos que você faz nos pacientes
que nós temos em comum, né? Então
agradecer pelo pelo pelo cuidado, né? Eh
que você tem. Eh, e a esse esse é um
momento muito eh muito importante. O o o
simpósio integrativo, simpósio
internacional de saúde integrativa é um
evento eh muito importante para auxiliar
na divulgação do RPCOD. Eh, eu como
membro da Alzheimer Survivors
Foundation, eh, que é uma instituição
filantrópica que se destina a auxiliar
na divulgação eh do protocolo Recode.
Eh, fico muito grata eh a por esse
momento dessa live, pelo simpósio que tá
para acontecer, pelo seu convite eh para
poder palestrar no simpósio, né? Eh,
dentro da fundação, eh, eu faço parte do
Advisor Board, que é o Conselho
Consultivo, eh, aonde, ah, a gente tem o
papel de, eh, de divulgar a, assim, eu
fiquei responsável pela
internacionalização da divulgação
internacional do Recode. Eh, então o seu
simpósio tem um papel eh importantíssimo
eh paraa divulgação do Recode no Brasil.
Eh, e eu como membro da Fundação dos
Sobreviventes do Alzheimer, eh, sou
muito grata eh a você pelo seu trabalho
eh nessa direção, né? Eh, e só fazendo
parênteses, essa fundação ela é formada
eh não só por profissionais certificados
no método, mas também por eh pacientes
que sobreviveram à doença, que
conseguiram reverter o declínio
cognitivo da doença, como a Jude
Benjamin, que foi a patientero, foi a
primeira paciente que reverteu a doença
eh em 2012, eh utilizando o tratamento
com protocolo recod. Ela recentemente
fez uma travessia a pé que durou mais de
6 meses. Desde abril de 2025 até 15 de
novembro de 2025, ela ah começou a
caminhada dela pisando no Oceano
Pacífico em San Diego em abril e
atravessou o território americano de
oeste eh a leste eh terminando a
caminhada dela eh a colocando o pé nas
águas do Atlântico em Santo Augustin na
Flórida, né? eu estive presente lá nesse
trecho final da caminhada dela, eh, a, e
tive a alegria de conhecê-la, eh, que é
uma pessoa que conseguiu reverter o
teclínic cognitivo da doença, eh, e, eh,
o, transformou a experiência que ela
teve com a doença em motivação para
levar essa mensagem a outras pessoas que
precisem, né? Então, eh, os
sobreviventes da doença existem, né?
como é um tratamento novo, é pouco
conhecido. Além dela, eh, Luci Voletsky,
que é outra sobrevivente, estava conosco
na caminhada, faz parte da Fundação dos
Sobreviventes do Alzheimer. Então, eh,
elas e outras pessoas que se
beneficiaram no protocolo recode, eh,
tão, eh, eh, estão trabalhando para que
o protocolo recode seja difundido eh eh
para que mais pessoas que tenham
indicação, seja pessoas com doenças com
a doença de Alzheimer, com estágios
pré-demciais, como declínio cognitivo
leve, pessoas com outras doenças
degenerativas que acometam a memória, eh
pessoas que tenham qualquer queixa
cognitiva, todas essas pessoas têm
indicação. de tratamento com protocolo
Record. Então, eh
essa eh em nome da fundação, eu agradeço
eh pelo seu convite, né, tanto paraa
live de hoje quanto para palestrar no
CIS e pelo todo o esforço que você tá
fazendo para que o SIS aconteça e seja
um grande sucesso de divulgação eh do
protocolo. Gratidão. Gratidão a você.
Muito obrigado, viu? Obrigado mesmo,
doutora.
Muito bem. Eu queria agradecer a
oportunidade de estar aqui com a Poliana
que nós fizemos após junto, né? E a
gente não se fala muito, né? A gente não
tem muita oportunidade de conversar e
foi muito bom ter essa essas informações
que ela me passou. Não sabia que você
tinha participado do final da caminhada.
Eu tava acompanhando pelos e-mails, né,
do do Recode, essa história muito
interessante dessa caminhada pelos
Estados Unidos, né? Eu não sabia que
você tava tão envolvida com isso. Eu
achei bem interessante.
E realmente vamos trocando ideia, vamos
fazer um evento aí maravilhoso, né,
Rodrigo? Se Deus quiser, Deus não vai
nos abençoar paraa gente poder
eh informar as pessoas da melhor maneira
possível sobre esse protocolo que já
existe há uns 8 anos praticamente e que
muito pouca a gente sabe.
É muito importante essa divulgação e
você tá dando esse espaço e por isso sou
muito grato, Rodrigo, eh, por isso. Bem,
ficar te elogiando aí seria um pouco
redundante da minha parte, porque a
gente já é praticamente irmão, né? A
gente faz live o tempo todo aí com muita
frequência, então você já é irmão, então
ficar te elogiando, o pessoal deve tá
até enjoado, né, de ficar escutando e
elogiando o Rodrigo. O Rodrigo é um
parceirão, um cara de um coração enorme,
maravilhoso,
uma pessoa aí que muita coisa
é um gentleman, como eu costumo dizer
para ele. E a gente vai fazer inclusive
um evento maravilhoso, com certeza todos
vocês estão escutando, pessoal, vocês
vão ter acesso livre, tá? a parte
geral ali dos standes. Mesmo então que
vocês não se inscrevam para ver as
palestras, vocês podem ir lá tomar um
café comigo, tomar um café com o Rodrigo
e com a Moriana.
E vai ser uma experiência muito legal de
ter vocês lá para vocês aprenderem sobre
eh essas questões são muito importantes
que, infelizmente, a mídia não divulga.
A mídia fica só divulgando drogas
caríssimas com efeitos colaterais
terríveis, que a gente não tá dizendo
aqui que não tem indicação do Lecanumab,
do Aducanumab,
tem indicação sim, mas eh são drogas que
não atuam na origem do problema. A
origem do problema é multifatorial e
enquanto
a mídia esconde isso das pessoas, né?
Então o trabalho da Poliana aí com a
fundação é fundamental e não sabia desse
trabalho dela, fiquei sabendo agora. E
se eu puder ajudar, eu vou ajudar nesse
trabalho. E nós vamos conversar mais
sobre isso, né, Poliana? Depois para
entender melhor como é que funciona
isso. E a gente precisa realmente nadar
contra corrente, porque a gente fala tem
umas coisas que não interessa o sistema,
não interessa o establishment. Então a
gente precisa ter muita força, muita
resiliência para poder realmente
divulgar
coisas que muitas vezes não depende de
um medicamento super caro, né, da da Big
Farma, né? Não que a gente não tá eh
desvalorizando, dizendo que não
funciona, mas que realmente, como eu
falei, a Dra. Puliana também reforçou o
estudo Evantea tá mostrando que os
resultados são muito superiores quando
você tem uma abordagem multifatorial.
Então, queria agradecer a todos vocês aí
pela presença, pedir desculpa pelos
problemas técnicos. Eu vou comprar o um
microfone pro Tudo Rodrigo, certo? Que
ele tá precisando. Vou dar dar de
presente para ele.
É, eu tenho aqui que tava sem bateria.
Eu também vou, eu descobri também que
talvez eu seja um dos culpados, né? Eu
tava usando um fone sem fio junto com o
microfone. Talvez eu seja um dos
culpados aí da parte técnica não ter
sido perfeita, mas a gente vai trabalhar
para as próximas vezes ser melhor.
Pessoal, eu não tenho como agradecer a
vocês por estarem participando, né?
Vocês sabem que nós viemos com uma
missão para cá que é, eu acredito que a
de vocês é bem parecida com a minha, que
é servir. E isso que vocês estão
possibilitaram hoje aqui é exatamente
isso. Então, queria agradecer mais uma
vez esses dois grandes profissionais que
vocês são que me inspiram a mim e a toda
a nossa equipe aqui da 25 odontologia.
Sou fã dos dois de carteirinha e é por
causa de vocês que eu fiz o programa
Recode e espero que vocês continuem
esperando milhares, milhões de pessoas
aí no caminho de vocês. Que Deus abençoe
muito vocês, a todos que nos assistiram.
Um abraço especial pro Martin Wis, que é
o presidente, né, Poliana, da associação
e que
é um dos é um dos membros fundadores,
os membros fundadores e a gente tem se
comunicado e eu vou tá participando aí
sexta-feira dessa live aí que vai ter.
Então, muita gratidão a todos, um forte
abraço para todo mundo aí e a gente se
vê lá no Sis. Até mais. Obrigada,
Rodrigo. Um beijo grande. Obrigada.
Fiquem com Deus.
Obrigada. Fique com Deus.
Outro.